- Our next guest rocked it
at the 2008 Olympic games,
where she won gold on the balance beam.
Then she rocked it on
"Dancing With The Stars"
when she took home the
mirror ball trophy in 2009,
let's say hello to Shawn
Johnson, everybody.
(upbeat music)
(audience clapping)
All right, so first of all, hello, Shawn,
how ya doing?
- Great.
How are you?
- I am doing really well.
So which were you prouder of winning,
the Olympics or "Dancing With The Stars"?
And note, I might judge you
on this answer. (laughs)
- Honestly, probably
"Dancing With The Stars".
- Are you serious?
You can't be serious.
- I am a like the shyest
person in the entire world.
I knew I was like pretty
good at gymnastics.
Like, you know, you can sing, right?
Yeah.
- I, I could not dance.
I wanted to lock myself in a
bathroom and cry and go home.
So when I won the mirror ball trophy,
I felt like I conquered Everest.
- Oh, I love that.
So it's like, basically that's,
it was more about the
emotional state of everything
and you accomplishing something
you never thought you would.
Okay, I take my judgment back.
Okay, I accept your answer.
(laughs) So,
so what are the best and hardest
parts of parenting for you?
- Well, I have an 11 month old
daughter and she's my first.
So everything is difficult, but
she is the light of my life.
- So you basically don't sleep,
that's what you're saying. (laughs)
- Yeah, never.
I live off of coffee and caffeine.
But, (stammers) you know with your kids,
it's just like seeing her
grow up and learn and smile
and love life with just such
innocent beauty is just,
it makes me love life even more.
- They slow you down,
definitely, in a good way.
So you recently partnered
up with Duracell.
Can you tell us about that?
- Yeah.
So, I mean, as a new mom,
I feel like you do
everything in your power
to protect your babies.
And Duracell had approached us
and I was reading all of their research
and this story about Marisa and Cameron
and found out that lithium
batteries are so toxic
and dangerous to babies.
And I just felt like as a mom,
the fact that I didn't know about it
means I feel like a lot of
other moms don't know about it.
So I was just trying to use,
lend my voice in a platform
to share really educational
and great information.
- I think that's amazing.
We actually have a mom with us
who knows all too well
how terrifying it can be
to have a child swallow a coin battery.
And you were just mentioning her name.
So let's let's welcome, Marisa everybody.
Hey, Marisa.
- Hi, Kelly.
- Hi.
So tell us what happened
with your son, Cameron.
- So Cam is, he's our youngest of three,
and one, it was just a normal Saturday
and I was getting ready for
work and we were playing
and all of a sudden I just noticed
he stopped like singing with us.
And I looked down at him
and he was just kind of hunched over
and I just knew something was wrong.
And so, you know, we rushed
him, we got him in the car,
we rushed him to the emergency room
and they took x-rays and they found
that he had swallowed
a lithium coin battery
and he was rushed to the OR,
and it was a surgically removed.
It was lodged in his esophagus
and it had burns inside.
We were in the hospital for 4
1/2 to five months with him.
And thank goodness now, a few years later,
he is doing great.
I never knew how dangerous
these things were
in our everyday house, you
know, where kids can reach them
and it's just important to just educate
and share Cam's story
so everyone just knows
how dangerous it is in our homes
with our little babies running around.
- I'm secretly panicking right now.
'Cause you don't think
like, oh wait, well,
batteries are in everything.
Like, you know, it's so hard.
And my son, especially
my four year old boy,
loves to take things apart
and put it back together.
Like, oh Lord.
It's just such a scary thing.
So, Shawn, what is Duracell
doing to help protect families?
Why'd you join up with them?
- Yeah, so like you were saying,
it was a panic attack from my end as well,
because you find these
lithium coin batteries
in thermometers and
sometimes birthday cards
and baby toys actually have them.
So Duracell actually did this
new initiative and campaign
where they changed all the packaging.
So it's like child-secure packaging.
And then they also coated
these lithium coin batteries
in a non-toxic bitter coating,
so that if a baby goes to ingest it,
it discourages them from swallowing it
and they'll spit it back out,
which is just another way
to kind of protect our little ones.
- Wow, that's so clever.
Like what a clever way to get around that
'cause they will spit it out.